a sensible naturalism would start with
the things that are part of what we can
all agree or the basic fact furniture of
the universe
some of them will include abstract
things like constitutions and shorter
equations and things like that whereas
we're confident that there are tables
and chairs we're not as confident that
there are numbers and things like that
and that's sort of it so that's now once
if one were to decide that numbers and
irrational numbers and square roots and
innumerable infinite are part of the
basic fabric of the universe then it
seems that you'll have trouble with
certain kinds of naturalism in
particular your kind of naturalism
because clearly such things don't look
as if they're made up of fermions and
bosons the problem for us natural ists
it's related to that other moose in the
middle of the living room recent problem
for us naturalist is to give a
naturalistic account of meaning and
foresight yeah okay and the difference
between you and me is my pet is that
we're not yeah that we're gonna discover
that not that meaning and foresight are
just more overlay very useful okay
perhaps indispensable given our culture
and way of life but without the kind of
relationship to the rest of science that
would vindicate their reality this is of
course what the rest of this weekend is
about another side and understand
meaning I just want to so you saying
that meaning that we're not going to be
able to come up with a scientific
account of meaning because you'd say why
it's because I've already talked enough
but I gesture and say the work of Quine
okay or the work of Dennett on among Qi
there or Searle using it as a modus
tollens
there's lots of arguments on the table
about the difficulties associated with
giving a naturalistic account of meaning
and it's one of the strongest basis on
which the anti naturalist mounts his and
her opposition to naturalism right but
but of course we could aknowledge damp
without giving up naturalism right I
mean Naturals math course Angeles is a
program this is one of the most
important problems on the research
program of natural right but beyond that
I mean that is I would agree but beyond
that I think we could even if it turned
out that a scientific account I'm not
saying that it will but if it turned out
that the scientific account of meaning
is impossible to human beings it's
inaccessible it's epistemic getting said
we're just not gonna get down so what
right that doesn't actually give any
particularly good foundation so any
rejection of naturalism just set because
it becomes an agony from argument from
ignorance it just says oh well you guys
can like invent that because we can't
investigate the entire universe we can't
exclude the possibility that Santa Claus
exists fine if that's your Chanukah
proof it's not part of science or
natural the natural world is all that
exists the world is not divided into
separate realms within any useful way be
cold natural and supernatural
you